are you starting to get a little
impatient for injustice tues launch well
another story trailer has been released
and this time the spotlights on the big
bad Brainiac I'm Matt and this gamespot
News Update is ready to feed some dang
superheroes to a giant fish braeak is a
techno-organic being with a actually
never mind all you need to know is he's
a big angry nerd who likes to destroy an
abduct worlds anyway an injustice to he
blew up Krypton and then later
discovered that Superman was able to
escape now he's come to earth to finish
his job I knew Brainiac had to fit into
this story somehow but this trailer has
me even more curious than before we've
got the remnants of the regime the
villainous society and now Brainiac
there's even a spot in this trailer
where Batman and Superman seem to be
working together it seems like it's
going to be one heck of a clash and if
you want to keep up on all the news and
coverage we have planned for injustice
to then be sure to hit those like and
subscribe buttons injustice two launches
for ps4 and xbox one on May sixteenth we
currently know about 27 of the fighting
games characters and based on the
official website there's going to be at
least 11 more my fingers are crossed for
John Constantine anyway the next
character is set for an April
twenty-eighth reveal so make sure to
come back to gamespot to find out who it
is but in the meantime head over to our
channel and check out the official
breakdowns for scarecrow Gorilla Grodd
and a bunch of others super-powered
characters